in this video I want to prove some of
the basic properties of the dot product
and you might find what I'm doing in
this video somewhat mundane but you know
to be frank it is somewhat mundane but
I'm doing it for two reasons one is this
is the type of thing that's often asked
of you and when you take a linear
algebra class but more importantly it
gives you the appreciation that we
really are kind of building up a
mathematics of vectors from the ground
up and you really can't assume anything
you really need to prove everything for
yourself so the first thing I want to
prove is that the dot product that when
you take the vector dot products if I
take V dot W that is commutative that
the order that I take the dot product
doesn't matter I want to prove to myself
that that is equal to W dot V and so how
do we do that well and this is the
general pattern for a lot of these
vector proofs let's just write out the
vectors so V will look like v1 v2 all
the way down to VN let's say that this
is equal to V and let's say that W is
equal to w1 w2 all the way down to W n
all the way down to W a so what is V dot
W equal V dot W is equal to I'll switch
colors here v1 times w1 whoops v1 w1
plus v2 w2 plus all the way to V and W n
fair enough
now what does what does W dot V equal
well WV you know when I've made the
definition it's you know you just
multiply the products but I'll just do
it in the order that they gave it to us
so it equals W 1 v1 plus W 2 v2 plus all
the way to W and VN now these are
clearly equal to each other but because
if you just match up the first term with
the first term those are clearly equal
to each other V 1 W 1 is U
- w1 v1 and I can say this now because
now we're just dealing with regular
numbers here we were taking we were
doing with vectors and we were taking
this weird type of multiplication called
the dot product but now I can definitely
say that these are equal because this is
just regular multiplication and this is
just a commutative property commutative
let me see if I'm spelling commutative
commutative property of multiplication
we learned this and you know I don't
know when you learn this and second or
third grade so you know that those are
equal and by the same argument you know
that these two are equal then you could
just rewrite each of these terms just by
switching that around and that's just
from the community from basic
multiplication of scalar numbers of just
regular real numbers so that's what
tells us that these two things are equal
or these two things are equal so we've
proven to ourselves that order doesn't
matter when you take the dot product now
the next thing we could take a look at
is whether the dot product exhibits the
distributive property so let me just
define another vector X here another
vector X and you can imagine how I'm
going to define it x1 x2 all the way
down to X n now what I want to see if
dot product the dot product deals with
the distributive property the way I
would expect it to then if I were to add
V plus W and then multiply that by X by
the by and first of all it shouldn't
matter what order I do that with I just
showed it here I could do X dot this
thing it shouldn't matter because I just
show you is commutative but if the
distribution works then this should be
the same thing as V dot X plus W dot X
right if these were just numbers this is
just regular multiplication you would
multiply it by each of the terms and
that's what I'm showing here so let's
see if this is true if this is true for
the dot product so what is V plus W V
plus W V plus W is equal to is equal to
we just add up each of their
corresponding terms V 1 plus W 1 V 2
plus W 2
all the way down to VN plus WN that's
that right there and then when we dot
that when when you dot that with X 1 X 2
all the way down to X n what do we get
well we get V 1 plus W 1 times X 1 plus
V 2 plus W 2 times X 2 plus all the way
to VN plus W n times X n all right I
just took the dot product of these two I
just multiplied corresponding components
and then added them all up
that was the dot product this is V plus
W dot X let me write that down
this is V plus W dot X now let's work on
these things up here what is V dot let
me write it over here what is V dot X V
dot X we've seen this before this is
just V 1 X 1 oh no no vectors now these
are just their actual components plus V
2 X 2 all the way to VN X n what is WX
WX is equal to W 1 X 1 plus W 2 X 2 all
the way to W n X n now what is what do
you get when you add these two things
and not notice I'm just adding here I'm
adding two scalar quantities that's a
scalar that's a scalar we're not doing
vector addition anymore so this is a
scalar Connie and this is a scalar
quantity so what I get when I add them
so V dot X plus W X is equal to V 1 X 1
plus W 1 X 1 plus V 2 X 2 plus W 2 X 2
all the way to VN x and plus W and X and
I know it's very monotonous but you
could immediately see we're just dealing
with regular numbers here so we can take
the X's out and what do you get this is
equal to 1 right here this is equal to
we could just
take the X out factor the X out V 1 plus
W 1 X 1 plus V 2 plus W 2 X 2 all the
way to VN plus WN X n which we see this
is the same thing as as this thing right
here as this thing right here so we just
showed that this expression right here
is the same thing as that expression or
the distribution the distributive
property seems to or does apply and the
way we would expect to the dot product
and I know you're so mundane why are we
doing but I'm doing this because show
you that we're building things that we
couldn't just assume this but the proof
is pretty straightforward
and in general I didn't do these proofs
when I did it for vector addition and
scalar multiplication and I really
should have but you can prove the
commutativity of it or for the scalar
multiplication you could prove that
distribution work for it doing a proof
exactly the same way is this a lot of
math books or linear algebra books just
leave these as exercises to the student
took because it's mundane so they didn't
think it was worth their paper but let
me just show you I guess the last
property let me just say associativity
the associative property that doesn't
matter where so let me let me show you
if I take some scalar and I multiply it
times V some vector V and then I take
the dot product of that with W if if
this is associative the way
multiplication in our everyday world
normally works this should be equal to
and it's still a question mark because I
haven't proven it to you it should be
equal to C times V dot W so let's figure
it out what's C times the vector V C
times the vector V is C times V 1 C
times V 2 all the way down to C times V
N and then the vector W we already know
what that is so dot W is equal to what
it's equal to this times the first term
of W so C v1 w1 Plus this times the
second term of w sze v2 w2 all the way
to C
n WN fair enough that's what this side
is equal to now let's do this side what
is V dot W I'll write it here V dot W
done this multiple times this is just V
1 W 1 plus V 2 W 2 all the way to VN WN
I'm getting tired of doing this and
you're probably tired of watching it but
it's good to go through the exercises
you know someone asked you to do this
now you'll be able to do this now what
is C times this so if I multiply some
scalar times this that's the same thing
as multiplying some scalar times that so
now I'm just multiplying a scalar times
a big this is just the regular
distribute distributive property of just
numbers of just regular real numbers so
this is going to be equal to C V 1 W 1
plus C V 2 W 2 plus all the way to C V n
WN and we see that this is equal to this
because this is equal to this now the
hardest part of this I remember when I
first took linear algebra I found when
when the professor would assign assign
you know prove this I would have trouble
doing it because it almost seems so
ridiculously obvious that hey well you
know obviously if you just look at the
components of them they just it just
turns into multiplying of each
individual components and adding them up
and those are associative so that's
obviously so what what's there to prove
and it only took me a little while that
they just wanted me to write that down
this you know they didn't want something
earth-shattering they just wanted me to
show when you take go component by
component and all you have to do is
associate is assume you know the kind of
distributive or the associative or the
commutative property of regular numbers
that you could prove these the same
properties also apply in a very similar
way to vectors and the dot product so
hopefully you found this reasonably
useful and I'll see you in the next
video where we could use some of these
tools to actually prove some more
interesting properties of vectors